- [Narrator] We're told
a factory makes toys
that are sold for $10 apiece.
The factory has 40 workers,
and they each produce 25 toys a day.
The factory is open five days a week.
What is the total value of toys
the factory produces in a day?
Pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
All right, so let's
just think about a day,
before I even look at this information.
If I could figure out the value per toy,
and then multiply that
times the number of toys,
number of toys produced in a day,
then we would have the total value.
And let's see if they
give us that information.
Well the value per toy,
they say the toys are sold
for $10 apiece, so we
could write this this way.
10 dollars per toy,
and then they do tell us,
or they give us the information
that we need to figure out
how many are produced in a day.
We have 40 workers, and they
each produce 25 toys a day.
So the amount that's produced in a day,
is going to be 40 workers
times 25 toys per worker.
Now I could say 25 toys
per worker per day,
and that makes the units
a little complicated,
or I could just realize
that this entire expression
I'm creating is talking about one day.
So the total number of
toys produced in a day
is going to be the
product of these things.
And we can say that the units work out,
just to make sure that we're
getting in the right direction.
A toy in the denominator cancels out
with the toys in the numerator, workers,
when you multiply it, this
would be in the numerator,
this in the denominator.
So workers, workers cancel out.
And so I'm gonna be left with
10 times 40 times 25 dollars.
And I do want it written in dollars.
And so this is going to be
equal to 10 times 40 is 400,
and then 400 times 25, let's
see, that's going to be
4 times 25 times 100 so
that's 100 times 100,
which is 10,000, and then the units
we're left with is dollars.
And now you might be
saying, wait, we didn't use
all of the information and
that's true, we didn't use
the fact that the factory
is open 5 days a week.
We didn't need to use that information.
That would have been useful if they said,
what is the total value of toys
the factory produces in a week.
Then we would have said their
value per day is $10,000,
and we could even write
it this way, per day,
and then multiply that
times 5 days in a week,
and that would have
given us the total value
of the production in a week.
But that's not what they're asking for,
so we don't need that other information,
and so we don't have to go to that step.
And so this is really
just extra information,
probably to distract you a bit.